digital marketing is the art of
connecting engaging and influencing the
world through the power of internet in
2024 it's not just a career it's a
dynamic Journey Through The Heart of the
digital age why because digital
marketing offers Limitless opportunities
for growth and impact with businesses
shifting their focus online more than
ever the demand for digital marketing
experts has skyrocketed it's your chance
to write the wave of innovation reach
Global audiences and shape the future of
marketing so here everyone and welcome
to Simply learns YouTube channel in this
video we'll take you through the top 10
highest paid digital marketing job roles
in 20124 but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these kind of videos and
find them interesting then subscribe to
our YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply as we know the demand for digital
marketing job roles has already
skyrocketed in that case if you're
looking to master the field of digital
marketing then look no for further than
the simply learns postgraduate program
in digital marketing in collaboration
with the perdu university gain in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
with this course you'll also learn
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
optimization and much more so unlock a
whole toolbox of skills including SE
ranking hoot suit Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube Twitter Google ads and
Keyword Planner so don't miss out on
this opportunity Find the course link
mentioned in the description box for
more detail so without any further delay
let's start this video on top 10 highest
paying digital marketing jobs in
2024 at number 10 we have an e-commerce
specialist an e-commerce specialist is
like a digital store manager they help
businesses sell things online they
ensure the online store looks good and
works well so that people can easily buy
stuff they also decide what products to
put on the website and how to show them
to customers e-commerce specialist may
run ads online to bring more people to
this store and they keep track of what's
in stock so customers can get what they
want their job is to make online
shopping easy and enjoyable for everyone
talking about the qualifications of an
e-commerce specialist to become an
e-commerce specialist you typically need
to know about online selling and have
some related skills you should
understand how online shopping works and
be good with computers knowing about
digital marketing website design and how
to use e-commerce software is important
too plus being organized and good at
problem solving can make you a great
e-commerce specialist talking about the
salary of an e-commerce specialist the
average salary of an e-commerce
specialist ranges from rupees 4 lakhs to
6 lakhs perom in India and in the United
States they get a salary that ranges
between
$38,000 to
$62,000 perm with additional cash
benefits at number nine we have an SEO
export they help improve the company's
website to rank organically in search
engines the they use various techniques
specializing in identifying the trending
Focus keywords keyword in-depth analysis
and understanding the competitors
strategies talking about the
qualifications of an SEO expert a
bachelor's degree in marketing good
knowledge of SEO and well versed in
using various techniques and Analysis of
the competitors talking about the salary
of an SEO expert the average salary of
an SEO expert in India ranges between
rupees 5 lakhs to rupees 8 lakhs perm
and the same SE expert working in the
United States earns around $47,000 to
$78,000 per year with additional cash
compensation moving on to number eight
we have a payperclick specialist or
expert payperclick managers are crucial
in securing a prominent position for
websites in organic search results
payperclick advertising offers a rapid
way to achieve relevant visibility it's
important to note that simply increasing
the bid does not guarantee higher ad
visibility factors such as his ad
relevance and quality score play a
pivotal role in determining top
placements skill in optimizing ad
relevance is the Hallmark of a
proficient PPC manager talking about the
requirements to excel in this role a
bachelor's degree in marketing and a
strong grasp of digital marketing
principles are essential talking about
the salary of a paperclick specialist
the average salary of a PPC specialist
ranges between 3 lakhs to 10 lakh Rupees
perom in India while in the United
States the salary ranges between $50,000
to $80,000 per anom with additional cash
benefits the salary figures might change
depending on the skills you acquire and
the company you work for next up at
number seven we have a Content
strategist a Content strategist is like
the captain of a Content ship in the
digital world they plan create and
manage all the businesses content like
blogs videos and social media posts they
figure out what the audience want set up
a schedule for when content goes out and
make sure it fits with the company's
goals they also monitor how well the
content is doing and make changes to
improve it basically they make sure the
right messages reach the right people at
the right time helping businesses
connect with their audience online
talking about the qualifications of a
Content strategist they often have a
degree in marketing or related fields
and they are good at writing and
understanding what people like they use
data to see how well the content is
doing and make it even better being
creative and knowing about digital
marketing are important and they might
need to manage project and work with a
team talking about the salary of a
Content strategist the average salary of
a Content strategist ranges from rupes 5
lakhs to 10 lakhs perom in India and the
same content strategist working in the
United States get the salary that ranges
between
$62,000 to $100,000 per anom moving on
to number six at number six we have
social media marketers social media
marketing uses social media to promote
Brands and services they create content
manage and measure the campaigns they
use various platforms to reach out to
new customers the main goal of social
media marketers is to meet business
objectives by creating content for blogs
and websites to get more traffic talking
about the qualifications of a social
media marketer a marketing degree is an
add-on to the job social media marketing
managers can work for media outlets for
example e-commerce we websites
Publishers and big companies they must
understand how to prepare the marketing
strategy for various social platforms a
digital marketer must create content
that resonates with the audience talking
about the salary of a social media
marketing expert the average salary of a
social media marketer ranges from rupees
3 lakhs to 6 lakhs in India and in the
United States they get a salary that
ranges between $50,000 $100,000 perom
with additional cash compensation moving
on to number five we have we have visual
designers a visual designer is a
creative professional who specializes in
designing the visual element of various
media including digital and print
materials the primary focus is on
creating visually appealing and
effective design that can communicate
messages Concepts or ideas to an
audience visual designers work with
various Design Elements such as color
typography images layout and Graphics to
create aesthetically pleasing and
cohesive designs they often collaborate
with clients marketing teams or art
directors to ensure that their design
aligns with the overall goals and brand
identity of a project or an organization
talking about the qualification visual
designers typically hold a bachelor's
degree in fields like graphic design or
visual communication and showcase the
expertise through a diverse and
impressive portfolio proficient in
graphic design software and
understanding of typography color theory
and layout principles along with
attention to detail are key
qualifications visual designers often
work with clients or teams to translate
Concepts into captivating visuals that
align with the project goals and the
brand
identity talking about the salary of a
visual designer the average salary of a
visual designer ranges from rupees 5
lakhs to 10 lakhs in India and in the
United States they get a salary that
ranges between $70,000 to
$110,000 perm with additional cash
compensation moving on to number four at
number four we have a brand marketing
expert a brand marketing expert is
responsible for maintaining and
increasing the company's reputation
Goodwill and the brand they work with
clients to prepare strategies to improve
brand awareness and increase lead
generation a brand marketing expert
helps identify new opportunities for new
products and
services talking about the qualification
of a brand marketing expert brand
marketing experts must usually have a
bachelor's degree in marketing and be
good at social media companies
businesses and marketing firms can
employ brand marketing experts the new
bees can start building their resumés
with internships and part-time jobs good
brand expertise must emphasize on
customer satisfaction loyalty program
and social media campaigns talking about
the salary of a brand marketing expert
the average salary of a brand marketing
expert in India ranges from rupes 6
lakhs to 11 lakhs perom and in the
United States they get a salary that
ranges between $50,000 to
$120,000 perom with additional cash
benefits moving on to the top three
highest paying digital marketing jobs of
2024 at number three we have marketing
analyst the marketing analyst is
responsible for helping companies to
reach the Right audience by collecting
analytics they gather information on
customers preferences and demographics
then they use this information to create
strategies to increase sales and
generate more profit they added identify
the type of content that will appeal to
a specific group of customers they work
closely with the marketing team talking
about the qualifications of marketing
analysts candidates must have a
bachelor's degree in marketing computer
science or management companies from
different sectors such as consumer
services retail outliers entertainment
and advertising agencies can employ
marketing analysts the average salary of
a marketing analyst ranges from rupees 5
lakhs to 13 lakhs in India with
additional cash compensation and in the
United States they get a salary that
ranges between $660,000 to $91,000 perom
with additional cash compensation at
number two we have digital media manager
a digital media manager is responsible
for bringing traffic to the website
through online advertisement on
platforms like Google Facebook and
Instagram they need to identify which
platforms are most suitable for reaching
the ride audience and be creative in
their skills to get the best input
optimization for greater output talking
about the qualification of digital media
manager a digital media manager needs a
bachelor's degree in management or
marketing finally let's talk about the
salary of a digital media manager the
average salary of a digital media
manager ranges from rupes 6 lakhs to
rupes 10 lakhs perom in India and in the
United States they get a salary that
ranges between $57,000 to 96 ,000 with
additional cash benefits the salary
depends on the skills you acquire and
the company you are working for finally
at number one we have the digital
marketing project manager role a digital
project manager is a person who prepares
the planning designing and development
of digital projects they need to work
with clients to understand the needs and
timelines of each project and check the
output they need to ensure all the team
members follow the same plan talking
about the qualifications of a digital
marketing project manager they should
have a bachelor's degree good
communication skills and good knowledge
of digital media they can be employed by
various companies like software
development marketing firms and web
design agencies they need good
experience in that industry by working
as digital project managers talking
about the salary figures of a digital
marketing project manager the average
salary of a digital project manager
ranges from rupees 10 lakhs to 19 lakhs
per anim in India and and in the United
States they get a salary that ranges
between
$68,000 to
$17,000 perom with additional cash
compensation and there you have it with
that we have come to the end of this
video on the top 10 highest paying job
roles in digital marketing in 2024 I
hope you found this video valuable and
entertaining please ask any questions
about the topics cover in this video in
the comment box below and a team of
experts will assist you in addressing
your problems so thank thank you so much
for watching stay safe and keep learning
with simply loar staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning in or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to n up and get certified click
here